mais là messieurs bonsoir on appelle ça
le piège blanc hier la montagne a tué a
frappé lourdement 12 morts sept dans les
pyrénées 5 dans les alpes
parmi eux l'ancien champion de ski jean
pierre oger 12 morts dans des avalanches
à titre de comparaison la route a fait
43 victimes pour tout le week end et
l'année dernière
ces grandes coulées de neige avaient tué
cent dix huit skieurs
pourtant hier ce sont pas comme
d'habitude le redoux et l'imprudence qui
sont à mettre en cause le thermomètre
n'a pas brusquement baissé au contraire
c'est l'absence de contacts entre la
neige fraîche et la neige déjà durci qui
a provoqué les avalanches quant à la
prudence
il est difficile cette fois d'en parler
jean pierre oger n'était pas un novice
et les autres skieurs ne s'était pas
écarté des pistes